so we have this larger triangle here and
inside of that we have these other
triangles and we're given this
information right over here that
triangle b c d
is congruent to triangle b
c a which is congruent to triangle e c d
and given just this information what i
want to do in this drawing i want to
figure out what every angle on this
drawing is what's the measure of every
angle so let's see what we can do here
so let's just start with the information
that they've actually given us so we
know
we know that triangle bcd
is congruent so b c d is congruent well
we know it's congruent all of these
three triangles are congruent to each
other so for example b c d is congruent
to e c d and so their corresponding
sides and corresponding angles will also
be congruent so just looking at the
order in which they're written b
a vertex b corresponds in this triangle
in bcd
corresponds to vertex b in bca
b c a so this is the b vertex in bca
which corresponds to the e vertex in ecd
so all everything that i've done in
magenta all of these angles are
congruent and then we also know we also
know that the c angle
so in bca sorry bcd this angle
this angle right over here is congruent
to the c angle in bca
bca the c angle is right over here or c
is the vertex for that angle in bca
and that is also the the c angle i guess
we could call it in e c d but an e c d
we're talking about this angle right
over here so these three angles are
going to be congruent and i think you
could already guess a way to come up
with the values of those three angles
but let's just let's keep looking at
everything else that they're telling us
finally we have vertex d over here so
angle so angle so this is the last one
in where we listed b so in triangle bcd
this angle
this angle right over here corresponds
to the a vertex angle in bca so bca
that's going to correspond to this angle
right over here it's really the only one
that we haven't labeled yet and that
corresponds to this angle this vertex
right over here that angle right over
there and just to make it consistent
this c should also be circled in yellow
and so we have all these congruencies
and now we can come up with some
interesting things about them first of
all
here angle bca angle bcd and angle dce
they're all congruent and when you add
them up together you get to 180 degrees
if you put them all adjacent as they all
are right here they end up with a
straight angle if you look at their
outer sides so you have if these are
each x you have three of them added
together have to be 180 degrees which
tells us that each of these have to be
60 degrees that's the only way you have
three of the same thing adding up to 180
degrees fair enough
what else can we do well we have these
two characters up here they are both
equal and they add up to 180 degrees
they are supplementary and the only way
you can have two equal things that add
up to 180 is if they're both 90 degrees
so these two characters are both 90
degrees or we could say this is a right
angle that's a right angle and this is
congruent to both of those so that is
also
that is also 90 degrees and then we're
left with these magenta parts of the
angle and here we can just say well 90
plus 60 plus something is going to add
up to 180 90 plus 60 is 150 so this has
to be 30 degrees to add up to 180 and if
that's 30 degrees then this is 30
degrees and then this thing right over
here is 30 degrees and then the last
thing we've actually done what we said
we would do we found out all of the
angles we can also think about these
outer angles so this or not the outer
angles where these combined angles so
angle say ac or say angle a b e so this
whole angle we see is that whole angle
is 60 degrees this angle is 90 degrees
and this angle here is 30. so what's
interesting is these three smaller
triangles are all they all have the
exact same angles 30 60 90 and the exact
same side lengths with and we know that
because they're congruent and what's
interesting is when you put them
together this way they construct this
larger triangle triangle a b e that's
clearly not congruent it's a larger
triangle it has a different
measures for its length but it has the
same angles 30
60 and then 90. so it's actually similar
to all of the triangles that it's made
up of